who's Johnny Bench he's on his way in
he's finishing up his uh interview
before us Johnny Bench
you know Jim I'm gonna do this like my
hand like like like I'm waiting for the
ball to get thrown hmm there is many
people catcher extraordinaire you we
should close the curtain by the way so
you get good video we don't people
walking by many people consider him to
be the greatest catcher of all time you
know that yeah that's right I've heard
that he played for a little team called
the Cincinnati Reds thought it would be
from 1967 to 1983 allegedly okay
two-time World Series champion whatever
big deal MVP in 76 okay yeah that's what
you say and there he is Johnny Bench is
entering pleasure how are you welcome
thank you very thanks for having me
thanks for coming in this is good this
is good welcome we are live or the
afternoon this is the morning stuff yes
yes technically how are you doing I'm
doing great we're having a great time
being able to talk about our Smithfield
school app yeah how did you get involved
in the with the with the Smithfield
school app well I've been involved with
apps in the past and we've sort of
studied between cities and all the
things that go along with it but more
importantly I have young children I have
boys that are seven and ten and you know
little things at school is sort of pop
up you know that in the you know in
kindergarten and preschool and it was
like we started investigating a little
bit more and finding out that this was a
possibility and so we found a developer
to provide all of the information that
that each app would provide and we've
developed this app that and we started
talking to Smithfield about it and they
said we want to be a part of this
because suicide is the third leading
cause of death for teens and a lot of
it's because they're being cyber bullied
and a lot of the social media the way we
have it today these kids are going home
and they're getting bullied over those
texts or emails or whatever it never
stops where you at what we're when we
were growing up you could walk away from
school and at least kind of collect your
brain possibly it's now never and never
have a fight after school me
my own sexuality a lot of questions well
you live with you know yes that's great
that's my last fight I think was
probably after school me you know fifth
grade attention leading up to it was
like three hi it's scared to death and
everybody else I got I got thumped a
couple of times and a couple of guys
after me and everything else and it
wasn't very good and I stood up to them
but you know back in those days you
could well with this app where all the
schools will be able to have their poem
platform they'll be able to design it
they'll be build the way they want to
they can fix it up you can go into the
and then all users whether it be the
parents students alumni can download it
into their phones in their mobile device
they'll be able to gets calendars
schedules events scores you can get push
notifications you can be alerted to any
kind of situation that we are on
lockdown all kids are safe so the
parents know exactly that everybody's
alright they can be alerted to closure
school closures well your kids getting
bullied he's like we got to do something
like well it made you want to do this
what was happening that was the reason
and part of it but I think it's more
importantly is that's all you hear about
is kids getting cyber bullying when you
started talking about the the number of
suicides and a lot of it were blamed on
the cyber bullying then then I had a
real problem with it so when talking to
smithfield we developed the app now it's
called it and you can go to Smithfield
school app comm and sign up if you're a
school all over the country it's
available now go ahead were you a good
fighter when you're a kid or no no I'm
looking at your hands you're obviously a
great athlete but your hands
Johnny Bench guy has massive hands like
you I really don't know I was only known
for holding seven baseballs who exactly
are you oh yeah that's what you gotta be
nothing I just noticing something
everybody else noticed in 71
I'm an [ __ ] sorry well there's no big
thing no I was small I was like five two
in the eighth grade and I'd gotten in
school a year early and I grew about
nine inches the next two years but there
were a couple of kids that pushed me
around a little bit and they tried to do
it I busted one in the mouth and I got
the went to the principal's office got a
board used on me but it was worth it man
much of it do you think is that people
are bullying more now and it's constant
and how much of is it the way that kids
don't fight back
well you can't fight back and it's
almost scary what they fight back with
because now they bring their weapon to
school it's no longer when Gilbert could
pulled a knife on me at school in the
fifth grade that was kind of dangerous
as well but now kids in order to
retaliate to get even they come out with
the big weapons and so I think that this
is just something but it's just cutesy
little kids it's its little teenage
girls that are doing it or somebody's
jealous of the fact that he thinks she
thinks you're cute
so he's she's this hair boyfriend now
he's going to go after you and start
creating rumors about you and saying
things about you the totally unkind
totally untrue and they own and no
matter what you say you can't change it
you can't how much as much as you deny
deny deny people still believe it and
then you start to feel it and then you
start to withdraw and then your
schoolwork suffers the fact that your
own personality and your health suffers
so if I can if if this app will help you
know 20 30 40 50 percent or eliminate a
lot of the cyber bullying then we've
really done it say you're into this app
very much today it's been a long time
since you retired what did you do in the
time since you retired to now you got
this and you're really happy with doing
that with other things that you were
doing that were kind of similar to this
well I do a lot of motivational speaking
I talk about the vowels of success the a
eio use of life and I wrote a book
called catch every ball how to handle
life's pitches because everything in
life even your producer is is a is a
great catcher because everything a good
producer yeah yeah see that's bullying
that's bully that's only at the matchup
to know that's truth tell also I have a
scholarship fund I I didn't get to go to
college I started baseball when I was 17
and I didn't get to go to college I have
a scholarship fund with 84 kids on
scholarship so I've always thought about
education and what it means so I stay
busy with that and then I've got a 26
year old he went to Boston University
and I've got sons that are seven and ten
so I'm busy
how much different is it raising young
kids now than it was I guess the twenty
six-year-old though because you didn't
have to raise you would have had to
raise any kids when you were at the peak
of your baseball career no I've never
never really had to and I you know he
was born after my inductions yeah so
he's really you know he knows of me and
volleying these and my younger ones now
they you know
they hear it from everybody else or a
pair they understand who you are we like
to je that watch like do they understand
the magnitude of who you are you know
I've never showed them really a video or
anything else but a couple of times in
the plane a couple three or four years
ago when they were really young we'd be
standing there waiting to get off the
plane and they say this is my dad he's
in the Hall of Fame and it was like
where did you come up with that and they
know it and I don't it's I'm just dad
you know I I don't want to be you know
much more than that but at the same time
I want them to grow up to love the game
to love sports and participate and the
one Justin he had like 14 home runs when
he was eight years old
then he got hit by a pitch and then he
got hit by a throw and he's sort of like
a little gun-shy so he's a soccer player
right now and I'm the other ones uh I
think he's going to develop a microchip
and be player owner oh I want him to be
owner of the team and then if he wants
to play he can put himself in fear where
the money is for so it's as much as the
salaries is so much bigger you guys who
retired a long time look at that and go
can I just missed that by ten or fifty
no not at all I mean I made two million
in my entire career what would I do
three or four hundred million are you
crazy
I'll be flying in our mouth for the
Gulfstream and I'm saying hey I don't
need you alright did you make chili in
your whole career that was what about
who came to it to Wow I made eleven
thousand my first year as a rookie and I
was envious would you work for Sirius XM
I was Ricky the era mate Oh 20 as MVP I
made 40 as MVP again I made 80 shouldn't
there be some kind of thing where it's
like if people are going around still to
this day referring to you as the
greatest catcher that ever lived there
should be some kind of payment plan for
that right if you're one of the greater
I've talked to the commissioner
he brought up and I don't get I don't
get upgraded I don't get why I don't get
moved to the first a little in front of
the line at the movie theaters well I
mean I it just doesn't seem fair at all
you're absolutely right can we start a
campaign this may be my ten step yeah
that's Johnny
yeah what was it like in that time
period uh because you know not only were
you known as this legendary got the team
it was a legendary team but to share it
with a guy like Pete Rose who is so like
gloriously outspoken and obviously like
that the ristar you know cuz Joe and Joe
and I and Tony I mean we could sit back
and let him you know talk to the press
he was great for us you didn't like
talking to the press I reminded I didn't
mind it them they were delving into it
and it started sort of transferring over
when you know we had news reporters that
were looking for a story rather than the
game right and then it became all of a
sudden you know guys were afraid to talk
to certain guys because you weren't sure
what they were going to write I mean you
know a critic is a legless man who
teaches running so this is a situation
where you know we can go through all of
this and everything else but you know
when you go to work everyday with the
best players in the world and one of the
greatest teams in the world it was just
beyond belief and and we were fortunate
because we did have that kind of team
that still people today respect and
admire are you protective of your legacy
like you watch now somebody's talking
about like say a new catcher do you want
to make sure that they're not I love it
I just you know they're talking about
Sanchez now because he started off so
well and everything else I always say
let's wait six or seven years mm-hmm
because there's so many various guys get
hurt their knees go down we had Joe
Mauer from the the twins
unbelievable one the batting title of
and his legs stopped you know he just
lost his legs and now he's the first
baseman so I think anytime you talk
about catching we've got a Johnny Bench
award which is a college catcher of the
year and we've got like 13 of those kids
that have been nominated and won the
award or been a part of the final three
contests and and they're in the major
leagues like weeders today you know he
was he was one of our guys we got Posey
we got Zunino we got Suzie Suzuki we got
Clemens Iannetta the Castro kid so I'm
constantly watching all the box scores
to see how the guys are doing
who is the best army of assam and guess
yvonne rodriguez that's yeah it's hard
to beat that but there was a couple of
guys there's always been great catchers
but if they unless they
on the MVP or the rookie of the ER a
batting tyler homerun title we really
don't pay much attention to them but I
mean I loves Salvador Perez I just think
he's phenomenal who is he I know he has
been Sam does he's the catcher for the
Kansas City Royals I mean he is just
he's just phenomenally there's a lot of
them out there we just they're just not
putting it happen you follow baseball
just as closely as you ever have to this
day yeah is that just because you just
the love of the game has never gone away
for you oh is it even when you left
there wasn't a period of like let me get
baseball out of my life there was never
sort of a bitter whatever no I I retired
because I knew I couldn't be Johnny
Bench anymore right I couldn't play at a
level and I was taking money from the
team that I that I didn't earn and so I
you know I'm watching these guys and I'm
doing this stuff and everything else but
I was always still involved I was always
wanting this guy or that guy you had
favorites she had people that you'd been
associated with you knew and your
favorites became some kind of
Association whether they were part of
the award or whether they were just
great players like Mike Trout or you
know somebody that you really wanted to
watch or Stanton or you know and there's
all down Arenado
I mean you can go down and say all these
players are unbelievable and I and I
love watching people that are committed
to the game and love the game and play
the game as hard as they can how do
players treat you it's gotta be guys you
retire like who aren't Johnny Bench or
who aren't Pete Rose like players don't
really see them as royalty it's gotta be
nice to at least be in a position where
wherever you go back you're still the
guy in the room that everyone well you
know you they they know the name
obviously but there's a lot of these
young guys that really don't have a
sense of history they don't know really
yeah there's it's just you know they
wouldn't know if you mentioned a couple
players and you know that are in the
Hall of Fame but they wouldn't you know
they would know much at all so you had
that we met a couple people and they're
like this is Johnny Bench you know like
hey anyways I became well yeah I I will
name any names but it was kind of like
yeah okay this is good and it's like
okay fine I've doesn't matter I mean
I've still whatever they are they are
and but that's just part of the history
and a lot of them you know a lot of kids
40 30 39 40 percent of baseball now is
Latin so I mean they're not always
familiar and they don't always get the
TV and they don't get the news pay
they don't get the updates of what's
going on and in baseball so all they
ever wanted to do was play baseball they
were committed they grew up they
practiced they signed they come through
the minor leagues and they're in the
major leagues and all of a sudden
they're not really aware except of some
of the history of the Dominican or the
Venezuelan or any Cuban guys that have
played before them now they're involved
with that but not with the the former
players I said on how you don't know
Johnny bench's I don't understand that
even if you don't like baseball how do
you not know that name how on earth do
you like when people pick up on the fact
that you're doing something historic as
you're playing Thanks
not you he's been here he's looking this
way that you know I wasn't looking at
you that you're doing something historic
like you were doing like you became a
legend as you were playing and whether
it's the the fan support or the women
there have you had to have been throwing
themselves at you
I would imagine Johnny look very shocked
look at the catcher I don't know what
you look like the worst position be
nobody anyway but watch of America like
seven years in a row so I mean you know
that's all they could ever see anyway
he's correct he's like no no they found
out who I was like how do you how do you
maintain focus on the game you know they
mean like yeah that's Umbra that's
something that's born within you but at
the same time you know you know we've
had him fixed so he should be alright by
now if you want to go out with him but
when you play with a level of what I
played with repeat joke Tony where
George Foster we had saves our Geronimo
Dave's concepción ken griffey I mean
when you play with like that there
wasn't anybody that was really much
better than anybody else we were all
equals as it turned out because we were
such a unit that we always wanted
somebody else to pick it up and we knew
they would and that was why we were so
successful in won the back-to-back World
Series so somebody could afford to have
a long night every now and then we you
know the thing about us is Sparky one
day when he was first managing he called
us in and he said all right you 25 are
going to the north you're going that
you've made the team there's two sets of
rules Pete Joe Tony Johnny you don't
have rules the rest of you guys and I'm
thinking all right I would like this
good man I thought then I realized what
this is and then he said you know I
don't have to worry about those four
guys
they know what it takes and knows what
it means so I don't think and and I
remember our first miniature day bristle
said son if there's there's nothing out
there after 12:30 that's worth taking
home and all it is problems and you're
not going to get your rest when I was 18
years old got him al anymore comes came
over to me son you're going to have a
great career there's three things you
have to do in moderation you have to be
near not drink so much you can't you got
to get your sleep and you got to watch
the women now did you take that advice
did you do trial by error I did III the
women were you know that's the hardest
why I had a weakness yes I had a
weakness for you and everything more
than one at once I uh as he asked me to
that's the hardest one to say no dues
you're a guy energy young young guy
playing at that level it's kind of hard
to say no not right oh yeah okay I don't
know it's a good time yeah you're cute
guy I would be no threat believe me I
would cause no injury speaking of uh you
know or you're talking about the the at
the the Smithfield school app and cyber
bullying and the way people behave on
social media Curt Schilling seems to
have taken the direct opposite route
that you have where you're seeing this
like Curt Schilling goes on social media
all the time and says the nastiest stuff
you could think of like when you see
that what goes through your head well
you know I was with Curt not too long
ago we did a thing of the Field of
Dreams out in Iowa where they shot the
movie and we walked through the
cornfield and everything else I think I
think a lot of people get upset with a
lot of things that are going on and
sometimes they really do want to voice
an opinion I mean they get so angry and
and Curt's not afraid to do this for
Curt Curt just wants to stand up and
think for things that he believed in
whether he believes in everything that
everybody else agrees with that doesn't
matter to him he's his own man you guys
have a show because you see things and
you talk about them and you have your
own slant or angle and everything else
and you can voice them aloud but you
know Curt has been brought fired two or
three times because things he said and
you know it doesn't bother him
doesn't bother him at all he's very
secure and who he is he's very secure in
who what he believes and because
somebody else doesn't believe the same
thing you know we see that throughout
our country now and discourteous
absolutely says you know he's he's going
to make it his way and if somebody's got
a problem with it tough that's the way
he is
see you respect the fact that anyone
speaking in mind and just being true to
who they are if you know where I I hate
hateful I eat hurtful and that's part of
what this app is all about hurtful
things that that create people I mean
you know when people come back on
Twitter and something and say something
because you've done something and it's
very spiteful I mean that's kind of a
bullying attitude when when you're
making things happen within a realm of
their issues or not message I say okay
I'm voting for Trump well well you can't
do I mean it's like so all of a sudden
you're this and and you want change or
you want something and everything and no
so you're this you're you know if you're
a Democrat you you're a Democrat if
you're a Republican you're 18 different
types of things right and you know it's
your conservative older conservative
this side or that side and everything
else I just want to change I want to see
things happen within this country that
are different I want to see where we can
run this country as a business and maybe
protect ourselves and be aware of the
fact that we've got a lot of problems
that we need to face I always wonder
about this so you have this great team
right and your men you're building it
and you're building it you're building
it in your building and then you hit the
World Series and you hit twice right
yeah and then free-agent comes along
free agency comes along dull it goes to
to the Yankees uh-huh and then I got the
first one to go yeah and then then all
of a sudden it became now you're old
you're 34 35 if they're you know Pete's
34 35 Tony's 34 35 Morgan's 34 35 and
you also have kids in the minor leagues
that are really talented kids and now
you've got to play them right so now you
got to make a space for them so Tony
Perez gets traded I cry don't you cry
many a trade I did I you know and I'll
admit to it anytime it's the only person
he was the greatest greatest teammate
greatest you know hitter and in the
clutch he was everything and he was my
friend and we we shared so many of these
things together so all of a sudden they
didn't realize
tony was really the glue of our ballclub
what kept everything together and kept
everybody stable and and it was just
sort of like you started to see the
beginning of the end how did you find
out he was traded uh my attorney called
me because he was representing Tony as
well and he called me and it just was
like no it cannot be true
it cannot be true and it was just a very
difficult difficult time for me I mean
it was a it was never going to be the
same because there you know all of a
sudden you know I always felt that we
were a lot very successful because they
had white leadership we had black
leadership and we had Latin leadership
you know and Tony led that and Joe led
that and Pete and I led that and we sort
of controlled the clubhouse and
everything else more importantly the
Latins that we had these guys this was
Tony the father you know everything that
they did he would talk to them about and
say you know you know you know can do
that you're not you know you don't know
can do that and he would basically just
say that's not what we are here we are a
team this is the way you represent
yourself as a major league player these
are the ways you always come to the park
every day you're on time and you do your
job and you and you play for us and we
play together would they get for him
starting to get a language layer woody
Fryman was he good and left-handed
pitcher from out of Montreal and good
stuff great so he was from Kentucky and
but it didn't we needed pitching but at
the same time Dan Driessen needed to
play first base and so that was part of
the reason and it makes sense in a lot
of ways but it made no sense to any
others that were close to the game did
you resent the guy that brought on no no
no no no that anybody was there was was
there if they came over Sparky Woodall
with a lot of time call us in the office
and say hey Pete Joe Tony myself it
would say what do you think we got Oh
bill know what about Jack Jack would be
great or we could actually go in and say
you know we like to get Jim well he's
will try you know because we knew these
guys would fit into our ballclub and it
wasn't necessarily they were starting
but the fact that they were great
backups and they could do the job as
well whether any that you almost got
that you said nah maybe we shouldn't at
all God why did we not get him was
Rennie the Overlook that you like I was
a terrible mistake that I don't know I
wouldn't
the front office they didn't really
share too but there was a couple of guys
that came over to our club and it was
like how did they get here it took about
three weeks and they they weren't there
anymore okay you know what you guys
complaining I let this case terrible
well he was a there was a couple of guys
there were pranksters all of a sudden
was the hotfoot in the bubble gum and
all this stuff and I was high school
junior high school stuff and that's it
that's not what this is about this is
not what the Big Red Machine is about
this is not the way we play right we're
out there to dedicate ourselves beyond
time play the game and we don't need
your sorry ass you know in there doing
tricks and everything else and running
around the clubhouse
yep eros doesn't seem like a hotfoot
kind of guy you know he was most
dedicated guy I've ever seen he wanted
to be the first hundred thousand dollar
singles hitter he was driven he was
motivated we were in business together
we that bowling alleys car dealerships
and but he was always he would say you
know you can hit 300 I said I don't care
if I hit 300 I know I can hit 300 but
I'd rather drive you in a hundred times
each year he never drove you crazy that
he was obviously focused while he's
focused on the team is also focused on
his singular goals of wanting to be that
way we all did no we were all that you
were okay you know I I did I had first I
was doing hit four slides in high school
but when I came up the Reds I didn't do
any headfirst slides because that was
his mantra and so know everything about
it made us better right his drive to get
200 hits and get a hundred walks and be
on base three hundred times for Tony Joe
myself it only made us better I mean it
we were we were perfect when it when he
because he was there but he never really
partied with Pete Rose oh yeah you did
sure okay go we all partied we you know
in the early days if you went to a
certain restaurant or bar after the game
was over you could take a team picture
we hung out together we really liked
each other and we certainly didn't have
enough money in those days to fly
anybody in I'm sure you're sick and
talking about the Hall of Fame Ajitha
just a general thing you think Pete has
been treated right because he made
mistakes or do you think he's been
treated totally unfairly no he's been
treated just the way baseball has said
you know if you do this this is what
happens you know you you have a set of
rules that tell people you go home you
tell your kids there's no more rules now
there there lies the situation but I've
been on a couple of different committees
to get him back into the Hall of Fame
and he
he had certain parameters he had to do
this this and this he's reapplied
himself but he wasn't able to sustain it
so uh it's you know I've always wanted
just to go ahead and get get help you
know sure go in and find out you know
you got a problem and come out and
realize I mean there's no you know
nobody's loved the game more nobody's
dedicated themselves more than Pete and
yeah I do still keep in touch with all
those guys yeah yeah as much as I can
Joe are really looking you know I'm
watching Joe very carefully he's having
a bone marrow transplant this month and
you know we're all pulling for him and
Tony I uh you know I text him the other
day because of the loss of Jose
Fernandez and I met the kid down in
spring training terrific kid terrific
talented di he's pitcher ain't ya a
buddy on Sobotka yeah it's just a great
kid and what I'm what he meant to the
game and the community but Tony you know
he was at it's close tie with him and
Tony introduced me when we went down to
spring training so you know to stay in
touch with him and then Pete the other
day we were talking about some things
and and we text back and forth and then
every now you know being who we are in
the 40 year reunions of winning the
World Series and we get we have certain
reunions and Pete was back for his his
induction into the Reds Hall of Fame and
so we were all back together and it was
all like walking right back into the
clubhouse
I mean it didn't faze anybody a bit they
started just on the same things started
talking about the same things and you
know it gets kind of you get a little
nervous because guys now you know Pete
75 Joe 74 20 73 for and you start
wondering you know we're going to have
another reunion in five years oh yeah
are we all going to yeah to be there it
it meant so much to so many baseball
fans and and it was cool just to be a
part of it did you ever you never
managed a team no I I would it would
have been like working oh you never want
to do take it you're not my son back
here is uh when he was nine or ten I
thought about managing you know so I
could have him around we were going to
the you know child custody and all that
stuff I would like to end been at the
park and been a part of it more but it
just never came to fruition so what did
you do right after you left baseball
like from he said umidollars done all
you don't either well we had the
baseball bunch and then we did
games people play I had a show earlier
in in the early 70s but I did a lot of
radio of CBS radio I did the World
Series with Vin Scully
you know just he's finished up a
tremendous career and I've always been a
motivational speaker so I've always gone
around the country and I anything that
you need done I can do and then I I got
more into what we're doing now and and
also a self chilling can I know we've
got a can now that you actually push the
twist it now it's a new twist bottom and
it goes from 80 to 40 and 50 seconds so
you had one hour self-heating I promise
that's really it was good for a guy in
the thing yeah for soup and for hot
beverages in the winter and watchword
these little things not another's a self
we we had to get together and just make
it like a little thing practical just
talking hotel right jolly well listen
you guys can get all the info you need
about Smithfield school app you go to
Johnny Bench comm you can go to at
Johnny underscore bench five on Twitter
uh and the Smithfield school up but come
this yet really great because it did is
depressing that [ __ ] you know
teenagers are just [ __ ] killing
themselves over the [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
not the happiest thing in the world no
we do it that growing up we had other
stuff but you know it wasn't constant
man but it's gonna be a great app for
you know school closures I mean you got
a bright you know you don't have to do
it you can report you can get all you
you know you saying well you got today
what's would your test coming ups I
don't know that and then the next thing
you go in I open up the app and I saw
see like you're testing schedule by here
you got one on Wednesday let's get
studying right so it keeps the parents
aware and alert and that you just lost
every teenager right that might want
that happen no more lion kids I think I
got dad will know when the test is
coming
no they don't have it oh really don't
mention that when you're trying to sell
that to young people just uh [ __ ]
building